let's jump to this story from
timcast.com ladies and gentlemen Trump
pack creates 2024 vice presidential
debate website trolling Fox News and
other candidates that's right Trump's
announced he will not attend the debate
Wednesday and apparently he said debates
he's not gonna do any of them which airs
on Fox News instead he will sit with the
Network's ousted former host Tucker
Carlson for a one-on-one interview
that's going to be really interesting
that'll be big
well here's the website VP debate what
is this the only person here is Chris
Christie oh okay when you format the web
when you shrink the website mobile yeah
it's like there we go there we go let's
uh let's zoom out a little bit and uh
battle for the vice presidency look
vivek's got 55 can I I can't scroll down
here can I I just gotta make it small
it's better for second place yeah look
at that
for the 2024 vice presidential debate
and Vivek ramaswami's got 55 actually
really really like this yeah uh I'm not
gonna watch debate I don't care about
the the GOP debate I would be surprised
if many of you intend to watch it oh
this is going to be we gotta watch this
we can't oh that sucks Fox News has
explicitly stated they will take anyone
down who rebroadcasts any portion of the
show Beyond a small amount a small
snippet uh if we do it after it airs is
that okay what a ridiculous dude it's
democracy this is the American Republic
you're supposed to proliferate the data
there is an argument that is it is a
newsworthy event they cannot make that
move but Fox News wants to play dirty
and assert that they will go after
anyone who rebroadcast the debate and
they don't have Donald Trump it was a
really easy decision for me to be like
oh well I don't care yeah that's too bad
because this is going to be way more
interesting than some crusty old dude
sitting out with Tucker Carlson
Trump and Tucker's gonna be crazy yeah
this debate
Haley talking to Mr Hutchins a
constitutionalist he understands the
Constitution and laws and he's going to
school everyone on stage about it sure
I'll watch the clips after the fact but
I don't I don't see I I really don't
look man I gotta be honest if it was
just Rhonda Sanders and Rama Swami I'd
be like this will be interesting but I
don't care about Nikki Haley come on
Mike Pence and Nikki Haley I'm back and
forth is a waste of my time yeah I would
be tuning into this for Vivek yeah but
they're not and he'll probably get more
speaking time because he's going to be
assertive but that still doesn't matter
they're they're is this are they
seriously gonna have Chris Christie
debating Nikki Haley
if you did Tim Scott Rhonda Sanderson
and Rama Swami I bet this will be
interesting but the rest of them just
make it not worth watching
this is a lot like remember just 2008
debates the Democratic debates where
like Mike Gravel was on the enemy like
you bunch of War Hawks even you
especially
especially Joe and you Hillary like he's
calling it up so good it was like 12 of
them and they only got like three
minutes each you know except for Hillary
and Barack and and they gave Biden some
time too so they'll probably do
something similar with this although I
don't know I mean this is like Trump's
version of of it at first I was like oh
screw Donald Trump mocking these people
and now I see he's put Vivek this is
basically Trump's way of saying Vivek is
the number two guy in the Republican
party right now all right so so uh put a
put a two in chat if you think this
debate is going to be worth your time
and uh put a nine in chat if you would
rather watch Donald Trump and Tucker
Carlson
here's my issue and I mentioned this
before the show and I'd like to I'll
reiterate it for you guys and the people
listening is that I was listening to
that Sean Ryan interview with vague last
night Vivek was saying how you know when
When Donald Trump was in office and he
wanted to end the administrative state
that you want to drain the swamp he
didn't know how so he asked his advisors
how do I do it and they said you can't
you don't have the authority because of
the uh because of the um civil
Protection Services Civil Service
protections act you can't fire people in
the ministry of state so Trump was like
okay
Alaska when Vivid looked into it he was
like oh okay well they told me I can't
I'm gonna go read the law myself I'm
going to read the Constitution myself
which is something Donald Trump has
never done so Vivek read it he realized
oh I can legally do it those guys were
lying to Donald Trump because they are
deep State and you can go in and re
reorganize and reformat the actual
organizations themselves the FBI
themselves you can gut you can just
terminate the FBI
you can't fire the individuals but you
can terminate the service and then re
reposition or lay off the individuals
and that's like Donald Trump doesn't
read I'm not saying he never reads but
he doesn't he's known for it it was
almost like yeah
this is why Tucker Carlson and Trump's
gonna be so interesting because Trump
gets his opinions from Tucker Carlson
and from the deep State apparently so I
don't want a guy a lot of advisor it's
going to be hilarious but no no no like
come on man 90 plus percent of Trump's
opinions come from watching Tucker
that's what he was famous for he would
tweet something at like two in the
morning and you'd be like yup he clearly
just watched that Tucker Carlson segment
and so now he's gonna be sitting down
with Tucker and it's going to be really
interesting and I want to add everybody
who's putting nine in chat
overwhelmingly overwhelmingly agree that
the vice presidential debate will be a
waste of time because there's no reason
to listen to Nikki Haley argue with Mike
Pence it's it's true and also like you
know I mean Trump and Tucker are like
the two most popular and most
influential names in in the conservative
whatever side of the aisle what if the
real reason they're doing it is that
Trump is going to announce Tucker
Carlson as his VP that's what Vivek
thought Tucker would be a good VP what
if tomorrow it's like this is not
actually an interview it's a discussion
about our potential platform I'm
announcing Tucker Carlson as my vice
presidential pick that would be kind of
hilarious dunk yeah I mean I mean it's
not going to happen but I I wish my big
problem real quick sorry no no we we
always talk about how great this
timeline is when silly things happen
yeah but if we really were in the
greatest of timelines it would be Trump
announcing in that sit down that they're
running together
anymore I don't get it I don't I he
wasn't the worst guy on Earth at all but
like he doesn't read the Constitution
why would you want that guy in charge of
your military
Barack Obama was a constitution he was a
lawyer like a litigator he understood
the Constitution inside and out and so
does Vivek like the only reason that
Barack Obama knew anything about the
Constitution is so he could make laws to
get around well he looked at the
Constitution as an in as an in well he
looked of the Constitution as a bad
thing because of what it does which is
inhibit the federal government Barack
Obama as a constitutional lawyer is not
a good thing it was so that way he could
defeat the Constitution he was not a
friend of Liberty or a friend of limited
government or a friend of the
Constitution his knowledge of the
Constitution was exclusively so that way
he could circumvent the limits put on
the government by the Constitution well
I think he learned about it before he
became president and then once he got in
there he definitely got co-opted by the
Deep State well I mean yes he did but
this so this is this is this goes to two
different ways to look at the
Constitution right so the conservatives
look at the Constitution they call it a
dead document right it doesn't change
you look at it that's what it says
that's what it means Barack Obama and uh
progressives believe that it is a living
document actually I think they're liars
and just making an excuse so that way
they can get around the limiting factors
in the Constitution but they say that
it's a living document what that means
is you take what it says and you think
about today and you think well what is
going to be best for today and now and
then you say well that's what it means
which is a friggin lie and the reason
you know it's a lie is because if the
founders really wanted the Constitution
to be interpreted they wouldn't have put
an extremely difficult and stringent
method of changing the Constitution in
the friggin Constitution I wanna I wanna
add this too I can't speak for every
Trump supporter some people genuinely
think he's the best ever I just think
he's a rampaging bull that he's like
just an angry bull and he's going to
romp about and just wreak havoc in the
bureaucratic state but then they're like
but hold on hold on now now that sounds
pretty good to a lot of people the bowl
bucks and then kicks the door open and
they're all going like oh Jesus like the
Bulls rampaging around and jumping on
the sofa and they're freaking out now
imagine Vivek ramaswamy is rodeoing with
that bull riding on the back of it and
he rides in using that ball to bring in
some effective policy yeah that's why
I'm like I don't know if a vape would be
VP but that'd be fantastic even Tucker
that the the original selling point of
Ron DeSantis was as everyone was like
he'd be the he's the VP he's the guy
because he's younger tactful and
perceived and more procedural he's he's
a little bit more dry a bit more boring
but that makes him a better VP makes him
one of the best VPS and then he decided
he was the big dog and was going to run
a campaign into the ground and now he's
just like not out of the picture Vivek
ran the campaign DeSantis should have
run and now Vivek is in the prime
position according to this vice
presidential debate 55 of people were
like Vivek man I I think a trump Rama
Swami ticket would be absolutely
incredible I like the Bold metaphor I do
of Donald Trump because he's in there he
doesn't know which direction to turn
next he's just smashing what he thinks
he's supposed to smash and vivek's like
a wizard with laser eyes that has
surgical Precision where he goes in
evaporates areas of of walls and
structures that need to be evaporated
while leaving the rest he knows what
he's doing can can someone draw a
picture of like Vivek as a wizard with a
wizard staff and an angry bull with
Trump's hair storming into like
government you know yeah you know that
would be the greatest comic someone make
that on AI the ball is just rampaging
around as the Deep State bureaucrats are
running in panic and then Vivek is
making hovering violent cabinets
disappear yeah it's his surgical
Precision that I appreciate the whole
like burn it all down mentality is just
it got people fired up in 2016 it
angered so many people with its
vagueness and uh and then you get a guy
that comes in there who's specific about
how he's gonna dismantle the Deep State
I see no other path than the specific
dismantling here's the other thing too
why isn't uh because someone's that one
gamer just super chatted Larry Elder is
not on the debate stage he is
substantially more relevant than say
like
I don't know he's a Hutchinson I don't
even know who this guy is bargain
he was
just a breakfast club with him
he's he's polling well enough to be here
but Larry Elder isn't that's wild yeah I
like Larry Eller his first fantastic his
like first words wrote Donald Trump too
his first words yeah oh like he's
complaining about Donald Trump no we're
thanking for president Trump but his
first words are about Donald Trump like
he's still in the comments people are
gonna are gonna Lackey for Trump how
many people how many of these people
what are there eight of them how many of
them do you think are going to mention
Donald Trump's name is this website is
praising Trump they're they're taking
quotes from these people praising Trump
on purpose it's not hard for Vivek I
think that's funny they got what Ron
Rhonda says I think Donald Trump has
done a better job appointing judges to
both the U.S Supreme Court and appeals
court than any other president my
lifetime including one of my heroes
Ronald Reagan yikes I man this
it's a special kind of ego to make a
website like this it was made by a pack
not by train oh okay yeah right people
who support Trump made this but to be
fair whatever kind of ego you're gonna
go ahead and talk about Donald Trump has
it it's just so disgusting yeah like he
I mean this is intimating that these
people are beneath him it's disgusting
that's exactly no they're not Vivek is
what trounces
yeah Vivek I would say is he's a younger
guy but uh he's he's he's on Trump's
level in a lot of respects I think in
terms of the
like
Vivek is not
I don't describe this Trump has that
Chieftain kind of like like pounding on
his chest you know Hulk smash kind of an
80s bravado with with troops yeah yeah
but that doesn't have that no but the
fake has other other powerful qualities
that I like yeah like being smart
yes like he's he's tactful he's
procedural he's he's surgical as Ian
pointed out he is in many ways a
balancing Force for Trump in the way
that we thought Ron would be he's just
not as hilarious As Trump he's funny but
he's not as hilarious Trump the shirt
off playing tennis was funny oh yeah I
laughed
so funny
I don't know but it was hilarious just
him like I want to know who he was
playing with that that motherfucker's
not real who's he playing that with I
don't know but the funny thing about
that clip is it didn't show the actual
game yeah it was just a clip of a vet
going ah he's like
lightning speed slam I love it was it
his wife was he playing with no I don't
know who advised him to make that video
but I appreciate it thank you I'm
starting to see if evix wife get
involved uh is approva is how you
pronounce her name she's a doctor uh
operating operating doctor I'm not sure
exactly but you were the in-house Vivek
expert and vivec fan you should you
should know that I'm a huge huge fan of
the intelligence and in fact I don't
even like him I like like what he's
doing I appreciate how he is working the
system he's just reminds me of like my
high school friends kind of like Middle
America Ohio he's an Ohio guy reminds me
a lot of my buddy Ted cortler class
president like go get him go get him V
like I knew you always knew you'd be
president man I think with the exception
maybe of vivec just because I know a lot
of his campaign is to some extent
self-funded or just let's see right
um I I do think that the other people
who are on that stage I know you said oh
Donald Trump thinks they're beneath him
I honestly do think that those people
are beneath Donald Trump and this is why
I say that because those people who are
running have absolutely no chance of
winning and it is all just an exercise I
think to divert a lot of money that
could be put towards much better
securing the ballot securing your vote
initiatives for Republican candidates
and I think the worst part when it comes
to people like Ron DeSantis the Tim
Scotts of the world that is just one
grift operation for the consultant class
that I think runs a lot of the
Republican party and if you want to get
into really what the issue with the RNC
isn't more broadly the Republican party
it's the entrenchment of these
Consultants who have absolutely no idea
what Grassroots or activists are into
and or care about whether they don't
know or they just pretend not to care
and all of those people who are running
it's just an operation to make those
people a bunch of money I think that
critique lands particularly well with
the DeSantis campaign but like I said
you have someone like Donald Trump who
the administrative state is waging I
would argue full-blown Warfare you're
talking four indictments you name it
against him and to see these people
adding on to the charge against him I'm
not saying that you know someone can't
be challenged that Donald Trump is a
king but I think in the historical
context and the level and gravity to
which the Deep state is assaulting him
right now for these people to be piling
on against him and having us divert our
resources away from really securing the
general election I think that does mean
that those people are beneath him thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time